this is the comedy piece for tonight
just in case you didn't know
Jeannie's doing it again because she had
it scheduled to do last week and her
partner
was called out of town so
we're gonna throw her to the wolves
where's summer
we're rolling sound is speeding we have
a mark
action
the three said we could um use the
Chapel to talk for a while okay
sure
oh my God what are we gonna do I don't
know
it's it's not fair not a bit
well maybe did that poor little things
you know you know it has a heart
and it's beating
how can that be
how can it have a tiny healthy heart and
everything else be so just oh
I don't think that's for us to
understand do we understand it well
enough
it is what it is it's got multiple birth
defects that's what the doctor said
can you please not color in it
her name is Melanie
she's a human she's her baby and she
belongs to you and me no that's not true
she didn't belong to me
no I'm only you either she's no part of
us
because what do you think those doctors
can do with surgery make her a whole
person out of sort of part like a
Frankenstein or something you're a
mistaken if you think that I can do a
damn thing
yeah well the doctor says we have to
make a decision by tonight so
I'm waiting for you to hear some of your
all your pontificating blabbing about
God because you don't want to believe in
that what does your God tell you to do
now
he tells me to keep her alive and care
for her forever you know it's been seven
days
if I remember correctly it seems
appropriate to me then on the seventh
day your God rested so today is resting
where where going fishing out to lunch
here and tell them I want to hear you
right now stop talking like that
don't talk about God like that whose
fault is it
we don't know why these things happen
Paul's fault is it mine yours it's not
anybody's fault fault I don't accept
that
please just please
yeah you know maybe maybe we shouldn't
have experiment with birth control pills
you know what and maybe you shouldn't
have experimented with drugs back in
your college day you heard me what
you're saying it's my fault because I
took drugs
you took drugs too it's your [__]
fault I need to know why our baby was
born like this
because it's God's will
and she's a special baby and and we're
gonna take her to special no no no shut
up shut up shut up no it's a mistake
honestly Christ they just gave us the
wrong one that that that that's it it
just gave us the wrong one
deal with this
look at me
I'm serious
I cannot handle this for the rest of my
life
you know what you know what I refuse to
be responsible for it nobody can make me
you know what
we're gonna go to those doctors
we're gonna tell them to do the surgery
and we're gonna tell them to give her
the best [__] chance
what chance do you think it has chance
for what no no no we
are going to we have to no we don't have
to
and we want going to it's not fair to
her
you know she didn't ask to be born
no seriously we wanted her
I love her
and I am going to those doctors whether
or not you want to because she has right
to live just as much as you do no we
won't and if I have to I will stop her
living myself
damn you
that's not in you
we are going to do this and God is going
to help us through no no I have heard
all I've gonna hear about your absentee
God
it doesn't exist [__] stop
stop girl
God is in you and God is in me
and we're gonna trust him
please
it'll be all right okay I promise you
promise
it'll be all right okay but we'll talk
we'll talk to the doctors again okay
just please
don't don't cry anymore okay
okay
very cut
oh okay okay good okay yeah okay that's
it for taping guys let's uh cold read